[Music]
hey
it's us again yeah we're back the hell
day is it it's tuesday right yeah yes it
is
when you're supposed to be turning it
it's all backwards
it's like like trying to do something in
a mirror
i know it drives me crazy you think that
i would be like used to it by now but
i'm totally not
every time i try to take the pictures
for my book review thumbnails
i always every single time i put the
book on the wrong side yeah and i'm just
like why am i
going backwards why am i so stupid i
don't know i just i can't
i can't get with it man i have no idea
why oh i see
you have no idea why what the reason it
went into screensaver because i had this
[ __ ] shut down
okay i got a new tablet it's taking me a
while to say yeah he got a new tablet
yesterday
so he's so he's just like i can't do
this he was trying to transfer
like last night he was trying to
transfer everything over to the other
one
chess is in there hey seth i was like i
was on
facebook a couple uh days ago and
facebook suggested you to me i said man
that's a girl in that chat in our chat
see there you go how did i don't know
how [ __ ] google knew that
because doesn't google own facebook i
guess it owns it yeah and youtube
i guess they just know even who's in
your chat
well yeah i mean because it's in your if
you're a subscriber
yeah like i imagine that they introduced
that's that's how they like filter
through all your [ __ ] right it's all
like algorithms and [ __ ] ai and [ __ ]
yeah it says do you know this person
basically yeah i was like yeah
yeah well because i get you know you get
synced like people that are on your
facebook they're like hey you want to go
join them on linkedin or are you going
to want to go join them on instagram or
whatever because you know what i mean
yeah they always find so uh
he jumps in and says uh happy tuesday
gotta go
oh well thank you for coming by you can
watch it later it's fine
yeah it'll stay up there and i actually
the other day
i actually this is how hardcore i am i
actually went in there and downloaded
every single one of our live streams and
backed them all up
in my dropbox yeah so i could so i'd
always have them because like i said i
had the audio versions before but i
wanted the video versions too because we
have so much of a visual component like
especially like
i want everybody to see how drunk we get
at the end yeah like especially last
week's show
where we don't even remember what the
[ __ ] happened they gave me my drugs
today i got my injections they gave it
all to me [ __ ] i can just
they told me to shoot it up here my
[ __ ] yeah you sure yeah you shoot up
yourself
yeah yeah it comes in a big bucket that
[ __ ] hurts it's like a um
it's the consistency of that [ __ ] is
like honey and you shoot it in there so
it makes kind of like a pill inside your
body like squishy it's like yeah they
don't want it they don't want all that
[ __ ] testosterone to go into your
bloodstream at once so it's just because
you might explode
you'll blow up your hulk you'll turn
green and hulk the [ __ ] up
[Music]
that's exactly what would happen yeah
got my blood work back
my numbers were [ __ ] bad they were
[ __ ] they were [ __ ] really old
yeah i actually went to the office with
him today because it's on the way to the
post office because
we had to go to the post office to mail
you know you guys a shirt and
i can't believe i'm actually alive i
can't believe and then i gained muscle
dear
when i when i heard them say like what
it was and what it was supposed to be i
was kind of like well okay yeah
if you're under 250 250 and under
you're [ __ ] like way
[ __ ] underneath the normal i was at
160
yeah 160. i [ __ ] my my [ __ ]
numbers should be up to people like
somewhere between 700 and 1000
well that's what you want it to be
that's that's the test level of a
[ __ ]
like a real hardcore for like [ __ ] 25
year old that's what you wet you want it
to be
but [ __ ] that was way below even a 50
year old
yeah i can't believe i looked and
feel as good as i do i mean i feel bad
but
man i didn't think it was gonna be that
low yeah it's like [ __ ] jesus
my beard's still gross
[Laughter]
so i was like well how long is it gonna
take for me to feel this and they said
probably about three weeks
and i was like i can't wait that long
damn
but i do kind of feel like it's going
slowly going in there it feels like you
hadn't had a cigarette in a long time
back when you was a smoker and you smoke
a little bit of cigarette you're like
yeah that kind of feels good
it's slowly going in there yeah it's
leaching into your musculature yeah it's
going in there we'll see how it goes
yeah it's probably taking me so long to
heal up after those workouts
yeah but uh anyway mango says
have you got your top 10 horror movies
sorted do you know what i did okay so
last night because
yeah we're gonna do it tomorrow night
here's what i did and i have to
refine it because i said this show is
gonna be 17 hours long
what i did initially i was going to take
the cinemassacre route and pick
like my favorite horror movies from
every decade because i was like how am i
gonna [ __ ] whittle this down there's
just no way
but i decided what i was gonna do was
that 1950s and before
since i haven't seen quite as many
horror movies like from the golden age
or whatever like i've seen a lot of them
but a lot of them i don't remember
so 50s and before i'm just going to do
like a top 10 or top 20 from that
but then after that i'm going to do a
top 10 or 20 for each decade because
there's no way i can [ __ ]
there's just no way i came up with like
1960s i had this
massive list 1970s i had a massive list
1980s at a
really massive list 90s and 2000s were
like a little sparser but we're still
like really really big
so i'm just gonna tomorrow morning i'll
get in there and like whittle it all
down
yeah and then we'll talk about it we'll
talk about it on wednesday
yeah so this show originally was just
supposed to be double feature
because uh louie sent us this right here
with yeah ouija and ouija origin of evil
washed it in the same night but we
watched a movie in between didn't we
didn't we see both all
we saw three movies that night didn't we
we watched that and then we watched
did we watch jiu jitsu in the middle of
it and then we watched part two so we
watched them the same night but like
right next to each other
but then so i was gonna talk about those
today and then but then last night we
decided to watch
um free state of jones on netflix so i
said well [ __ ] you want to throw that on
there too because
you know might as well we're not doing
another matinee this week so we might as
well okay that's from 2016 so that's
totally legit
so um all right so let's talk about the
first
uh ouija which came out in 2014.
now the thing about this this is
blumhouse michael bay was one of the
producers on it which i didn't even
realize
this is kind of like your blumhouse
formula which
i mean you have to give even some of the
movies aren't
fantastic you have to give them props
because
ouija the first one cost five million
dollars to make
and made about 104 million back yeah so
it's like a massive they are a massive
massive and like the it's um
and the audience is skew very young you
know what i mean like uh
teenagers 20 somethings like really
really [ __ ] love these and they will
just go see every single one
now the first ouija i feel like this one
um this is not bad it's like it's not
anything that stands out particularly i
feel like
was this okay now the whole ouija horror
movie boom
mini boomlet if you want to call it that
because there's like been a lot of luigi
horror movies was this kind of the start
of that i know there was some back in
the 80s because it was which board
that came out of 87 i think uh had
[ __ ] tawny katane in it the chicken
yeah the chick that was on the hood of
the car and that white snake video yeah
she was actually kind of like the mama
of the [ __ ] um
uh the den mother of [ __ ] all the la
early metal hair hair bands yeah tonic
she was older than i think people
thought she was and she was
scooping up on all these young rock
stars if i remember correctly well i
think she was in her 30s and 40s through
a lot of that
yeah yeah she didn't look it but she was
well you know that was great
yeah guys i know i know dudes that are
in their 20s are like oh man she's too
old
just tear themselves up over that
[ __ ] milf orange
cougar porn and they're like yeah she's
50 but you dude you're [ __ ] you're
[ __ ]
jerking it to this is the [ __ ]
funniest thing we're going all the way
to the [ __ ]
um going on the way the mail uh to the
to the [ __ ]
mailbox not the mailbox we got opposed
to the post office yeah and they're
[ __ ] some teenage dudes in the car
next to me and the driver keeps looking
at me and i'm [ __ ] looking at him and
he goes
are you scoping he turns it down turns
his [ __ ] rap music down you know he's
two white dudes and he goes how are you
doing sir
and i was just so weird we were just
like getting stopped
where are you going he goes i'm going
i'm going to the going to the beach
yeah they were going to i-4 to go to
town i guess what you can do down there
and you go smoke some weed and i said
why don't you drop acid
they're like oh no no no come on man be
a man drop some ass
they're laughing and they can run off
and [ __ ] i told him i said you should
know what that [ __ ] deal was with
that
i told him he said you should have said
ghost why don't you shoot up some heroin
we'll shut up
he's trying to [ __ ] i don't really
get what all that was about how old were
they i didn't even i didn't get a good
look at them probably about 19 20.
okay so we're kind of scoping you out
first and then they saw me
looking at him and then and then he
didn't want to be a puss so he had
he had the [ __ ] you know hey how you
doing little skinny guys here
i didn't notice that i just like said i
heard the music when they pulled up
because it went on
but i was just kind of like random kids
do
you know oh kids say the darkest things
yes
but yeah so all right so what happens in
this movie what happens in this movie is
pretty much what you would expect to
happen in a ouija movie in the sense
that somebody plays with uh a ouija
board and
[ __ ] ensues so what ends up happening
with this director
yeah well they think that they're
talking initially
that um you know they think they haven't
really got anybody but then the first
woman deb
or the first girl her and her friend are
doing it and then it
seems like she kills herself by hanging
herself with like a string of christmas
lights which i was like
glitzy but um obviously she didn't kill
herself it was some
spirit that did it so but her friends
all think that they committed suicide
that she committed suicide
so then they start using the ouija board
again like to contact her
and at first they think that it's her
that's talking to them and like they get
all this weird [ __ ] that's happening
outside of the ouija board like
everybody gets a little message that
says like hi friend on it and for a long
time they think that they're talking to
her
and then after a while it uh turns out
spoiler alert that they're not talking
to her that they're actually talking to
this not a demon but like a horrible
ghost
now um so like i said this isn't that
old a movie so i don't super want to
spoil it it's not like it's a big
like surprise or anything the
interesting thing
is that they give you like the whole
entire backstory which is like a pretty
good backstory right i mean
they think initially i will say that the
kind of twist in this i gotta check the
uh stuff oh you got ham on you yeah
we still have ham left over from now
that one was frozen though
oh this is a different ham i thought
this was the same ham like from saturday
that he came in eating
so i will say that the whole switcheroo
thing that you think
the bad person is not the bad person
this is kind of like the same twist
that happened i don't know if you guys
have seen
the haunting of julia which i think in
the uk is called full circle
it's actually based on a peter straub
novel which is just called julia
and a similar thing happens in that so i
don't know if they got the idea from
that or if it was just like
i mean it's not it's it's random enough
that it could have just been a
coincidence you know what i mean because
it's just kind of like oh you thought it
was this person but it's this person
because i feel like twister kind of
thing
so maybe that's not what it was but like
when i saw that i
that was immediately what it reminded me
of but
i don't know i feel like a lot of people
haven't seen that movie even though i
love it
so maybe not maybe i'm just like totally
talking about my ass
but the interesting thing so linshay is
in this did i say that she's in like a
bunch of the conjuring movies was she an
insidious
i guess i like a lot of the conjuring
movies but it's like they kind of all
bleed together so i can't remember
because i know there's a couple
different franchises in there and i know
that there's like some offshoot [ __ ]
i don't know i mean technically the
conjuring ones are like the warren
case ones yeah that's all bloomhouse
stuff though isn't it no that's
no that's james juan okay now insidious
i wait are there is [ __ ] the warrens
in insidious i don't even remember i
remember liking insidious but i can't
remember
they all kind of blend together that's
what i'm saying they're good but it's
like they kind of blend together
it used to be that they used to have all
these damn cable news
or cables cable television series that
actually people would watch like a
haunting
i got them all on dvd she she her a lot
of them on dvd she gave them to me yeah
i gotta unbox it bloomhouse kind of
picked up that market because people
don't really watch cable anymore
they're smart they do a very workmanlike
by the book movie
that still has a little bit of character
to it
but they don't do anything out of the
ordinary it's it's it's got its own
motif
and that's the way this first ouija it's
just like a creepy movie
that like when you go to the theater or
when you rent it or whatever it's just
you pop some popcorn you get some
[ __ ] snacks
you get some of your friends together
and you all sit around in the dark and
you watch it and it's creepy and fun
we're not talking about kubrick or
anything there's not a lot of artistic
flair in them
because why would you do that the
audience that's watching this these kids
they don't know what any of that is they
don't have those tastes they just want
to see something kind of different yeah
there's going to
they just want to they don't have those
cinematic tastes yet they have not yet
fully [ __ ] formed their own opinions
besides they would see the cool [ __ ]
that we like they would see that as like
old people stuff
they would say oh shining that's all
people's [ __ ] yeah
why why is it moving so slow what's up
why isn't there any music in this it'd
be [ __ ] like that
you know man so they don't have the
taste so what they do is they just kind
of make a pre-package
it's kind of like this is kind of like
the applebee's
a [ __ ] horror movie that's a good way
of putting it it doesn't offend anybody
it's nothing really that special and
every now and then it kind of hits the
spot yeah sometimes you're just like
yeah okay yeah that'll work that'll work
so and and they're cheap and they sell
well
well you know the production costs are
cheap and they sell real well so
it's a winning strategy really would you
think well obviously
i think all of their movies they
sometimes come out of the [ __ ] didn't
they do fantasy island
they did yeah which i actually liked it
i thought it was amusing
was it [ __ ] a masterpiece no no
it was an interesting premise for sure
it's the fast food of movies you're not
it is kind of yeah you're not there to
[ __ ] you know
see an oscar you're not there for
[ __ ] ben hur yeah or [ __ ] you know
like i said you just want to have some
snacks with your friends like scream
with your friends
that's all yeah and [ __ ] hernandez is
in there saying
yeah he's seen a bunch of kids in the in
the game yeah in every bloomhouse movie
we saw well actually
remember remember la la la la la la
yorona la irania that wasn't
that wasn't bloomhouse but that was that
was what's his name
that was from the uh the conjuring that
was james juan wasn't it or he produced
it i don't think i think that's a
conjuring word
but man [ __ ] some of these kids
they're just funny as hell because it's
like
they can't handle anything [ __ ] scary
they had this little
skinny [ __ ] latino kid and i could
hear them going oh oh
oh remember that then he'd [ __ ]
pretend like he didn't do that that
wasn't
he tried to play it i wasn't scared
he said i wasn't scared and the whole
[ __ ] theater [ __ ]
i remember that show was really funny
i was just having an asthma attack you
guys don't hate that [ __ ] was so funny
i saw the dude later and he's like
[ __ ] five foot nine and weighs like
[ __ ]
buck oh five i was just scared
yeah you were you were [ __ ] terrified
i like that people have somebody asked
us what webcam we were using can you see
what that even says
i can't even see what that says put your
glasses on oh [ __ ] they're making me
work man
oh my god imagine that i'll tell you
what i'll move it here and you can see
it
okay i don't know what it is i don't
know what it says i don't even actually
remember what that says it sounds like
it's just some
that's actually like a really cheap it's
a cheap one i just got on amazon
i think it was i think it was like
eighty dollars yeah i think i mean it's
a nice webcam but it's like it's very
very
simple and it's got like a little tripod
most of the cool [ __ ] is like we just
have all these like colored lights in
the background so that's probably what
you know what i mean and we have it it's
dark in here but just with colored
lights
because i don't know i like that it
gives it a little party athena did you
see the uh did you see the longer
version of dr sleep
because the director's cut's much better
than the yeah
can you push that down i can't really
even see the screen there you go oh okay
um yeah the i was [ __ ] with it the on
the on
when you can go online you can get the
director's cut it's better than the
theatrical edition it's got like an
extra half hour in it that really
fleshes it out
i want to say i one uh last thing i
wanted to say about ouija was that i'm
pretty sure
that the kid that was in it that played
pete who was the boyfriend of the first
girl that
committed suicide or got killed by the
ghost or whatever
i'm pretty sure that was the same dude
that was in the bye bye man
which i don't remember if that was a
blumhouse one or not but
i think that was like the first horror
movie well not the first one but the
first recent one
that i was like watching it and i just
didn't feel the need to finish it it
didn't piss me off or offend me or
anything i just couldn't get into it
and i never did finish it like the
trailer looked cool
and it had like some cool imagery in it
but for some reason i just i don't know
man i just never like caught the wave of
it and i just didn't care and then like
i just i was just like man [ __ ] this i'm
going to watch something else
and i don't usually do that so yeah but
then i think of that would make of that
what you will
one of our logitech oh you know what it
is a logitech thank you
um one of our regulars tila who was just
on here a minute ago
she didn't like dr sleep then i said see
the extended version the the director's
cut and she came back and she said oh
yeah it's it's a different movie
it is yeah it's a lot better well it's
got a lot more like stuff it's a lot
more like the shiny
it's it's more kubricky and she watched
them
the shining and then dr sleep the
extended cut
doctor sleep side by side and then she
really liked it
yeah yeah a lot of the same tone another
thing too i want to say about ouija i
guess this happens a lot but
um i guess when they first shot it
and then you know they do the thing
where they um you know have people come
in and watch it like test audiences
and apparently test audiences really
really didn't like it and so they had to
reshoot half of the [ __ ]
thank you and then they rash balls my
friend thank you that's for jones yeah
yeah whoever jones is who's jones
which jones wait free state of jones
though we're gonna be talking about that
maybe
thank you mango yeah we'll get to that a
minute um but yeah so
you know like i said this is it's a it's
a decent
watch i mean i wasn't bored i wasn't
like annoyed or anything like that it
was just like a fun
just a fun movie it's just fun um and
like i said i guess they
you know they did the right thing like
reshooting half the movie because it
ended up making like all the [ __ ]
money
so then uh they said well that made all
the money so
let's make a sequel so 2016 the sequel
came out now interestingly
they they kind of like threw around a
couple different ideas for this
initially they were even thinking of
making like a sequel but that didn't
really have anything to do with the
original
but then they got mike flanagan on board
and he was just kind of like man i see
like one i hate sequels but two he's
like i really want to
kind of go into the backstory so he
essentially made a prequel now i think
what's interesting about this
one he said that he really wanted this
to have the feel of a 70s horror move
like the changeling um he said he what
he made the director of photography
watched the changeling like a whole
bunch of times like before they made the
movie
and also he wanted it to be mostly made
with only [ __ ] that they would have had
in the 70s you know what i'm saying it's
got a good tone it really does
and it's it's like miles better than the
original it's just it's got its own kind
of thing and the first one
then the first one yeah what's
interesting about it is that
you essentially know what the story's
gonna be because they gave you the
backstory
of um you know of doris and all them
like from the
original like the ghosts from the
[ __ ] ouija board in the first one
so they gave you the whole backstory
like her mom was a medium and like you
know
she sewed her mouth shut and all this
other kind of stuff and
so the prequel origin of evil
is essentially just telling that story
from the 60s or
whatever it was i think it was like
supposed to be 1967 if i'm remember
correctly
um but even though you kind of already
know the story they kind of throw a
couple little curve balls in there
and but it's still compelling because
even though you knew the backstory
it's still i don't know just like the
tone of it is so cool and like i said
there's a bunch of um henry thomas is in
it and um
you know there's so a lot of you know
mike flanagan's act man you [ __ ]
blurred all my [ __ ] out
look what you did i did that yeah that's
because it's trying to focus on
yeah for a movie so like you keep moving
around
blackmagic film studio says i love
dragging me to hell we need to do that
one of these days i don't think you've
never seen dragon hell have you sam
raimi
uh no i don't think oh it's good i said
i saw that in the theater when it came
out it's like it's really
really entertaining super gross luigi
origin of evil is uh
um it's a lot better i thought it was a
lot better than the first well it was a
lot more distinctive
like i said you can tell a lot more
style a lot more style a lot more
personality it had
the tone was a lot better it wasn't
workmanship
like the first one it was it was uh it
was artistic
and it just had it felt more like film
yeah you know the first one kind of feel
like it felt kind of like cable tv a
little bit
a very high-end cable tv yeah it was a
little bit more of like a throwaway and
i don't
mean that to sound not a bad way
disgusting yeah
they just kind of like yeah we just want
to watch the scary you know make a scary
movie that a bunch of
you know teenagers and 20 year olds will
go see it's almost kind of like it
wasn't really
thought out that well it was just let's
get it done it ends up being kind of
samey
same tone same visuals same kind of
stories
this one felt very different the
acting's a lot better
uh yeah and it has a lot of actors from
that mike flanagan uses a lot
yeah including uh the girl that was in
oculus and when i say that
when i say the acting's a lot better
it's not like the other that there was
bad acting in the first
no that's not what it was the actors in
this one you can tell were
more into it it had more they were more
distinctive characters
you felt like you they were
you felt like you're you're learning
about them in this movie
the other ones you can tell they're kind
of cardboard cut out throwaway
characters they're not that important
they're not really drawing you into it
yeah i mean
you know they have like particularly
with these types of horror movies like
the first one you kind of have like
stock characters it's like yeah
here's the hot ditsy girl and here's
kind of the more serious dark-haired
girl
and here's the jock dude and here's like
the soulful poet type dude and here's
this that you know what i mean
so they always kind of have these stock
characters yeah this one's more
around this cute little girl her older
sisters who's like a cute teenager
and then their mom who's kind of like
you know a
cute chick in her 30s late 30s and
that's the same actress that was in
haunting of hill house and she was she
was in a bunch of other moments yeah and
paranormal stuff happens and it got
complicated quick and then people's
boyfriends get killed and this
it's just it was more like us and
what was funny is that when it started
with the fonts and everything and the
cars you can
tell this is the 60s yeah 60s late 60s
i think it was supposed to be 1967. yeah
and
they have good clothes like uh
the costumes that they're wearing are
six late 60s period stuff i can remember
people
as a little kid i remember people
dressing they're looking like that all
the way into the 70s
and you could tell that they didn't make
the same mistakes that happens in a lot
of western these new
cheap western movies where yeah that
kind of looks like western clothing but
that's rayon dude
yeah and [ __ ] they didn't have
polyester so you could see it was all
natural fibers for the most part you
know
people wore a lot of wools and cottons
and you know different tweeds and
the sweaters had a certain tone to them
because you know they were wool or
cotton and
it's just it's just not the same you
know
when you start putting modern materials
in in a in a period piece it came across
as a period piece so i liked it it was a
lot it was a lot better planned and
planned out a lot better thought out it
felt yeah
more high-end like i said you can tell
that
someone like mike flanagan directed it
who only kind of takes projects if he
really
kind of wants to he doesn't seem to
half-ass anything
right um everything i've seen of his has
been you know at least
you know interesting like he always does
really interesting things to it
it's funny because so the first ouija
like i said it cost 5 million and it
made 106 million
or something like that um however on
rotten tomatoes it only has six percent
positive reviews
origin of evil on the other hand um
didn't make quite as much money it still
made 80
80 81 million which you know was many
many many times its budget so it was
still like very successful
um but on rotten tomatoes it has like 90
positive reviews so you can see
so like the critics were like much so
this is like much much much better
um than it really had any right being
and
i s and the thing that really made it
really good to me not only is it a
period piece and it's really really well
done the characterization's really well
done it's like
it's really creepy but i like that he
took a story that essentially you
already knew because like i said in the
first one they kind of gave you
the backstory so you knew like who these
characters were and what was going to
happen
but he still made it compelling enough
that you really wanted to watch it
yeah yeah pat if you if you don't like
sami
i really wouldn't the first the first
ouija movie is
samey but it's good sami yeah it's not a
bad at all
but you're not gonna really walk away
from it with any kind of
distinct impressions if you ask me yeah
um
you want to see origins of evil that
one's that one's a lot better
yeah it's the prequel yeah it's and it's
just and you don't have to have seen the
first one
because it doesn't matter makes a good
standalone and i like to that origin of
evil goes into
because i love any type of like seance
type [ __ ] i love seance type [ __ ] like
especially like old school seance type
[ __ ]
like so like all the old school mediums
and people come and do all the [ __ ]
you know like in the haunted mansion
like i love that kind of [ __ ]
so i like that it focused a lot on that
because she was a medium and whatnot
all right what's your final verdict is
that it yeah yeah well um and then we're
going to talk about
uh free state of jones because we just
watched that last night
as well yeah so that was so this was
another one we actually hadn't planned
on doing like i said a third movie
um but because tom was in the mood
to watch free state of jones last night
which is on netflix at least in the u.s
i'm not sure about other countries
yeah this came out in 2016
and it's a historical
uh drama yeah which as far as i could
determine was
is pretty historically accurate the guy
that wrote it um
and directed it gary ross this he spent
gary ross yeah he's from he's probably
related to you i don't know actually
okay he might be related to you yeah but
he's my family my family and my dad's
side is from
the the free state of jones yeah so he
very well might be a distant
relationship and
and i know that my one of my kin
named david key who was a professor at
uh
ole miss university in terms of in
history um did a lot of the research and
wrote a book
about newton knight in the free state of
jones and evidently that ended up
inspiring this
this movie yeah okay uh wasn't the move
it wasn't
wasn't the guy you just mentioned though
yeah all right it's just that
it was it was my cousin basically he's
now in in i come from
an area where everyone is cousin or kin
even if they're not really related to
you
if your dad grew up with these people
there can
yeah and their their children can also
be considered cousins but they're not
blood relatives okay so david wasn't a
blood relative but we grew up together
for the summers yeah and our dads grew
up together and this went back for
generations
and our families knew the living nights
they're still there okay and
i'm getting ahead of myself
this movie's about newton knight and he
read
he's a uh during the civil war he fought
on the side of the confederacy but then
deserted from the federalist
confederacy went back to to jones county
and launched a basically a slave revolt
and
a uh a bunch of runaway or
a bunch of people that didn't want to
fight in the war and they
fought against the confederacy for a
while
and then when sherman turned him down
free state of jones conor for a while
was
in a state of war between the united
states and the confederacy so
i kind of come from a people that are
very
just we just say no to [ __ ] no
[Laughter]
there wasn't anything written about all
this it was
mostly it was but only authorities knew
about it yeah
and it's a fascinating story i'm
surprised there hasn't been more [ __ ]
about it they wouldn't teach
common people in jones county about
newton knight
it was legend and i grew up with these
legends and this movie confirms
everything that we were told as kids
about newt knight and
what had happened um
i loved this movie it was really good
and
it explained a lot of stuff it also
talked about jasper and jasper counties
because there was the jaspers too
jasper county and then it's weird you
know they're doing all these ambushes
and revolts in all places
where i used to go all the time like
elseville it's right near uh
is this right near um heidelberg
heidelberg
yeah heidelberg has a population of
maybe 700 people right now and it always
had the population of about 700.
this is taking place not in the modern
south but the old south the population
was one-tenth what it is now it's
it was it was just all farms it was all
farms
and bushwhacking and murders and
uh but it was a good place too um
even to this day mississippi is
the poorest of all the states
it's about 30 black which means it's the
blackest of all states
it's almost kind of like something from
south africa
it has the most guns per capita of all
states
but has one of the lowest crime rates of
any state
and has the highest um
not so much standard of living but
satisfaction you know
life satisfaction level our people love
it there it's fun place
if you don't make much money but you
don't need much money to buy anything
you could have get a nice house
real nice house for 300 a month in
certain areas
yeah i mean it's like kind of in the
middle of nowhere in the middle of
nowhere and it might be an 1800s house
yeah or early 1900s house but it has
three stories
and it's [ __ ] huge and it looks like
something off a [ __ ]
off a damn horror novel a magazine off
of a horror [ __ ]
poster or something from a horror movie
like a haunted house but it's only 300
bucks
then i challenge you to go try to air
condition that [ __ ] thing well yeah
you can't hear mississippi all y'all
can't air conditioning you can't
eat it you don't need to be there in the
summer with no air conditioning
[ __ ] that [ __ ] and then uh but anyway
jenny can give you the details of the
movie i thoroughly enjoyed this movie
it was actually really good it was like
it was i mean i was expecting it to be
good because i knew a little bit about
kind of the history behind it and but
yeah the guy that wrote and directed it
gary ross apparently
i mean sadly this movie only made like
half its budget back it got like decent
reviews but
you know it's one it's long it's like
two hours and 19 minutes so most people
are like man i want to sit through that
and you know i i don't know maybe that's
kind of what it was but
the dude that wrote and directed it he
had been working on this for 10 years
this was like his passion project
um he had made like some other kind of
bigger movies i keep oh [ __ ] man well
but i think he worked on the hunger
games movies actually now that i'm
thinking about it
but um this is really what he wanted to
make because he's like he was fascinated
by
this story and nobody had really done it
and
so he just spent 10 years like
researching the [ __ ] and if you look at
the end like all the historical
consultants there's like a [ __ ] like
a list of like all these historical
consultants
and um he was just like look it he he
found it fascinating that
because he's like this is something
that's not really all that well known in
american history
and there's not really a lot of movies
you know there's a lot of civil war
movies but there's not a lot of ones set
during like the reconstruction era
yeah and he's like a you know that's
just an era that's underrepresented in
film so he's like so i thought this
would be a really good
story to adapt because and it's like i
said as far as i know i'm sure there's
some [ __ ] in there for like you know
dramatic license or whatever but
this seems pretty historically accurate
the way that it was like i said
there's almost there's almost nothing
written about this when i was a kid
yeah it was just legends i'm sure there
were records but they were like
they were probably in town halls or in
police departments a lot of this [ __ ]
was
crime you know yeah
the confederacy was the was the
legitimate government at the time and
these guys were going out fighting
confederate soldiers and
murdering confederate leaders yeah all
right
and when you see how this so of course
it would have been
considered a crimes not warfare but it
was warfare it was
asymmetrical warfare a lot of
infrastructure attacks
burning people's cotton up yeah um
newt knight and all these guys that
didn't want to fight in that war did not
want to fight and die over cotton
and they found out that escaped slaves
didn't want to fight didn't want to die
over cotton either
and they were like living out in the
swamp they were living out in swamps and
stuff
cotton was when you think of cotton you
just kind of laugh at it but cotton was
kind of like the oil business of the day
yeah it was a huge industry people were
trying to make living
as farmers and um uh what do you call
them
uh sharecroppers but they just couldn't
compete against
plantations yeah plantations were the
oligarchs of
of the south they were kind of like the
bill gates and the [ __ ] zuckerbergs
of the south
they would just drive you into [ __ ]
poverty because you couldn't
compete with slave labor nobody liked it
um then
south started to try to secede from the
north and the north for some reason
didn't want to let them go
they didn't really talk about it too
much at the time
and really the secessionist movement
against the union
was was a conspiracy really against
very rich plantation owners they didn't
want to lose their money and their power
now were they willing to go out and
fight these wars against the
the of course not they're gonna they
were sending these poor sharecroppers
out
yeah well because they even they even
mentioned this in the movie and this is
historically accurate yeah that if you
owned 20 slaves
then you didn't have to fight and then
you didn't because you were rich enough
to not have to go
now when you see con when you see
american civil war
warfare they always show skirmishes and
standing battles with
cannons that really wasn't most of it
most of it was looked like world war one
it was trench warfare
and certainly and they do show that in
this show they did that very good
they did have some skarma [ __ ] but then
the rest of it was kind of like vietnam
where it was people bushwhacking people
in the woods
yeah ambushing people like that in the
[ __ ] taking their supplies and
killing them the economy
the economy of the south started to
crumble people started to starve
the confederacy would steal everybody's
crops and send that to the army and then
the the the people who grew it would
starve basically
it was just a bad time and then uh
you you had jones county was the main
one that revolted against it and they
were
sherman wouldn't help them though so
it's like he would but he only he gave
him like a third of what they wanted
so they were just kind of like man [ __ ]
that yes like [ __ ] [ __ ] the united
states too
and um there's a line in there where
newtonite says we've always
been well it's just he goes we're we are
our own country now we're the free state
of jones
and when you think about it we have
always been our own country
and because that's if you went there and
grew up there the mentality of the
people there is basically that they're
not in the united states
not really well and you have to think i
mean at their height how many
dudes did he have it was a couple
hundred and they had
actually taken over like three counties
maybe four counties
yeah so it's like there wasn't nothing
like it was kind of a big deal they did
take a big area because like i said this
during the civil war it was like little
skirmishes like companies weren't that
big
and they didn't have like real high-tech
weapons or anything so a few hundred
dudes
could do a lot of damage and could take
a lot of property and they did
and the war was really only or the the
so-called civil war was only half of
that war
once the war was over jones county got
shafted
again because
the revolt newton right the revolt
and and all that his followers were were
mississippi republicans and they were
being oppressed by things called
dixiecrats
which southern democrats were known as
dixiecrats
they were pro they were pro
um secession and uh they were
pro-slavery
even after slavery ended they were still
trying to reinstitute it with
new programs that was slavery but named
something else they copy-pasted the word
apprenticeship from there instead of
slave
and then they would just but they left
the rest of the law the same right
in mississippi and you had northern
carpetbagger families coming in
as part of the reconstruction to become
the new the new plantation owners
and they would adopt dixiecrat ways they
wouldn't
bring the north with them per se they
just adapted to the south it was
the movie talks all about it it's not
this clean
thing the reconstruction was terrible
then the dixiecrats hired
true the dicks if you were a dixiecrat
you were clan
adjacent yeah they would they would hire
the klan to attack
um southern republicans and
any blacks that wanted to vote to try to
keep them from voting
then when they would vote they wouldn't
count their votes so and it shows all
that i like
the only thing that i didn't like about
the movie is that they showed the clan
attacking the blacks
but then they kind of made it seem like
the blacks and the republicans did not
retaliate
they retaliated back and forth for
nearly a hundred years i mean they kind
of showed that a little bit but it was
mostly property
mostly property but yeah so
the civil war went all the way up to the
60s well yeah
in in jones county and it was just
that's why i said in some of the other
shows i said mississippi was the north
korea
of the united basic
war for about a hundred years it was
low-level
civil conflict yeah it went on a long
long
long time and what ended up happening
eventually is that
basically what ended up happening is
that the dixiecrats
beat the southern republicans into
submission
they eventually got
black people to vote democrat
so they could have segregation
which that sounds crazy but at that
point black people wanted segregation
because they wanted to be free of white
people
and safe yeah they had to be said you
can't blame them
and if you're it was quite a tactic
you got dixie kratz getting the clan to
attack blacks
so blacks would vote for dixiecrats
because dixiecrats wanted the separation
and that would keep both sides safe all
of this [ __ ] basically expunged from
mainstream history but that's how it was
really done i mean i learned about it in
school like back in the 80s at night you
wouldn't hear about it now probably
but it's just i mean little like little
stories like this
i you know i feel like they you know
because there's so much american history
is like so [ __ ] complicated and
you know they have to kind of skate over
a lot of things to get everything in so
i feel like this
is kind of a smaller story that maybe
wouldn't get told like in schools just
because
you know there's so many other details
and it's very local
right so um so i'm actually really glad
even though it didn't
do very well at the box office or
anything but i'm really glad that they
made a movie about it because it's
really like fascinating
and as i said it seemed like they did a
really good job trying to get it as
historically accurate as possible and i
have to say
matthew mcconaughey plays uh newton
knight i think this might be
the best role i have seen him in oh yeah
he's good
the only uh there's a couple of
inaccuracies
the accents are not very mississippi but
they're
passionate passable but not real close
um
there we had different
dialects based upon class it was
jones county was very
celtic and teutonic there was a lot of
irish
sounding southern accents
the rich people sounded british they
didn't have any southern accents really
they kind of had
okay they didn't sound british they
sounded trans-atlantic
yeah and here we are this is and i have
recordings of the way they spoke
you know and yeah that's why you get
that like when all those
recordings and stuff that's why
everybody sounds like they're putting on
that [ __ ] voice because they work
sharecroppers and blacks had southern
accents and there was kind of a fusion
between the two
now you said the one woman that was in
this that played the the barley the lady
that owned the
yeah the tavern that's that was a that
was that sounded like a real necessity
yeah
i should note that now one thing that's
inaccurate this actually was shot in
louisiana
and not in mississippi not mississippi
so the swamps that they were in
yeah look more like louisiana swamps or
it looks like the ever since i saw him i
go that's not in jones
it's a yeah it doesn't look like
mississippi swamp but it's a you know
swamps
the jones county or mississippi concept
of what a swamp is is very different
from the louisiana version of this one
but luciana swamp is a bio
all right or bayou and it's got
knees that come up out of the water it's
a forest underwater
a mississippi what a mississippian would
call a swamp
would be a pine forest
but it's got it's low it's a lowland
pine forest and it's got a lot of
shallow lakes in it
possibly a little river going through it
it's not you could walk through it but
you couldn't
take a big formation through it that's
why they were hiding in it
because and then they did skirmish lines
and stuff and and if you've got horses
into there they probably could go
could only get in there maybe two files
side by side so it would make them more
of a target with the weapons that they
had back then
can we talk a little bit too about i
like that they kind of went into this
a little bit um now newt knight
had a wife you had two wives and well
i'm just going to say he had a wife to
start with a white one and then
and then when he deserted and like ran
off into the swamps to hide because they
were looking to hang his ass
um he ended up meeting this other woman
she was a slave
she was a slave her name was rachel and
i don't know if that was her real name
but that was her name in the movie
and they kind of was her name yeah and
then like his white wife kind of took
off like for a long time
she ran to she ran to alabama yeah yeah
she took off for
for a while because she thought she was
probably in danger too which she
probably was
so i don't i don't know how long it was
several years that they were apart but
um
newt knight and rachel also ended up
having a kid
and they kind of jump ahead in the movie
a little bit every now and then
like 40s to the 40s yeah because i think
it was like 85 years like after the
civil war or whatever
and the descendant of those two
um he was
on trial because he won
he was one eighth black like his yeah
what would rachel have been his great
great
great grandmother something like that
was black and because of that
he couldn't marry a white woman even
though he looked as white as any other
hockey [ __ ]
and he was married yeah they married and
then they
found out yeah he got him on trial for
marrying a white woman this is back in
the 40s
yeah that's another thing that that he
had to bring up out of this damn race
war
when this during the uh reconstruction
the uh they they basically
beat the blacks into supporting
the democrat or the dixiecrat or
democrat party to get
segregation to happen that was the only
way they were going to have peace
segregation required racial separation
you couldn't
marry intermarry anymore yeah it was
illegal it was illegal
but that was a new thing that that that
wasn't around before
before the civil war going back all the
way to the 1700s
sharecroppers no matter what color they
were married each other including the
black ones
well and i feel like it wasn't just that
there was like a lot all
all different races kind of yes it was
indians there too i don't think people
were all that they were native americans
asians it was all
they weren't that concerned about it in
fact
in the 1800s by you know the war
happened around 1865 i think
1860 that's about when it ended
well before that time you know we're
talking about
in the 1850s late 1850s there were first
of all the population was very
small there weren't very many people uh
there weren't very many black people
but most of the black people at that
time were free
all right most of them weren't slaves
most of them were free sharecroppers
it's because they kind of had a they
kind of they would have excess slaves
and they'd
kick them out basically so they were
just walking around and they just became
free people
and they became sharecroppers and they
just they married whites
they lived right side by side on the
same little properties
the the whole segregation thing
was the dixiecrats attempt to unravel
the inter inter
interracial marriages that had been
happening for a long time
and akana in a way reinstitute slavery
is what it was it was a fake form of
slavery
the whole thing was [ __ ] nuts yeah
well
i just i just thought that was really
interesting that they kind of put that
in there that like his
yeah you know many years like 85 years
later like
like their descendant was like on trial
for
yeah marrying a white woman even though
he looked white too
yeah never i mean you know they didn't
really get into it that much
they got into it some but you they're
looking this
the the um mississippi in a way was
history would say well mississippi
alabama louisiana they were slave states
not really half the damn counties in
those states had it banned there was
already
a bunch of disagreement over most people
didn't think
most people were sharecroppers and they
didn't believe in that [ __ ] they didn't
think that you could own another man
now that mean that that there that it
was all kumbaya between whites and
blacks no no
no no not at all they didn't like each
other oh they saw black people as
competitors
they didn't want them around as a matter
of fact a lot of the same people that
were fighting for abolition
also wanted black people to be sent to
be freed so they get out of those
plantation but they wanted them returned
to africa and a lot of them went back
that's where some of those african
states came from
yeah that they were sent back uh they
had government support they were given
weapons and guns and tools and they went
down there
and rebuilt what was it it's uh ivory
coast i think is one of them i think
in libya in liberia they have american
flags as
damn national flags that's where they
came from but
it was just a messy part in in history
and this [ __ ]
show is messy yeah so i like that this i
like that this kind of goes into like a
lot of so i mean obviously like it's a
two and a half hour movie so it's like
they're gonna have to
you know cut things short cut things
short and window it down but i mean to
be fair i think they went a lot into
because
this covers a lot of ground it covers
like from sort of the early days of the
civil war into like reconstruction and
then like i said there's some parts
where it
jumps ahead so it can show like the
dude's um you know
descendant and how that worked out um
and i i was thinking about that one
scene where
newt knight was reading his little it
was i guess it's his
little constitution like for the free
state of jones and it was just like what
the constitution was
yeah it was just like so i thought that
was like kind of cool that they put that
in there and i'm assuming that that's
historically accurate or
you know i don't really know it probably
was i i think it was
it sounded pretty no man should exist to
make a
to keep another man poor well no man
should be allowed to keep another man to
become rich by making other people more
oh yeah he's talking about those
plantations
yes that's who you were talking about
that and then there was um
[ __ ] what were the other there were
there were three there were four rules
all together
and then there was one plant in the
ground is yours yeah that too
um if you walk on two legs you're a man
you're a man right yeah like
two legs you're a human being doesn't
matter what color you are yeah um and
then i can't remember what the other one
was
[ __ ] they were just kind of but they had
very very simple
yeah very simple it was just that would
have that would have been what
would have it was what was important to
share croppers
yeah at that time yeah yeah but uh no i
give the movie [ __ ]
two thumbs up it's really good like i
said it's long and it's like but i mean
but if you're into like periods like
historical drama if you don't know much
about this
time period i think it did a really good
job by covering it but seeing this movie
it it explained a lot that i was told as
a kid and it
a lot of the legends that we had turned
out that they were true yeah
and uh it explains why
you had to have a certain damn genome to
survive that [ __ ] and that
explains a lot about the way my family
is
yeah it really does yeah anybody
[Laughter]
all right so man we we went for an hour
today
yeah okay pretty good that's good all
right so tomorrow
night is wednesday when you guys know
what that means
that means drunken party stream and like
i said um
i'm gonna be talking about favorite
horror movies i'm gonna like i said i'm
gonna try to winnow it down but i'm
gonna have to try to winnow it down by
decade i can't win it down anymore oh
but you know what i forgot to mention
what's that
watch that free state of jones not only
is it informative it's a good movie
yeah like i said there's really good the
acting it is not a good action in it
[ __ ] bad [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] up newt
knight [ __ ]
joins up with these freed slaves one the
the one
his best friends the dude that played
the black guy from predators
um he also did the remember the one
where they're driving they're doing the
road trip yeah green book
green book yeah he's that guy he's a
wrestler yeah
martial he's a real good actor when he
finds him he's got this down
because he'd ran away before he's got
this iron collar wrong with these spikes
that go up like that he can't lay down
because his head's in a damn
cube and he's had it on for [ __ ]
years
yeah it's like yeah i'm just kind of
used to it now yeah it's pretty cool
but uh yeah you see the movie it's a
good movie it is a very good movie i
like i liked it a lot and
it lines up with everything all the
legends we had we were kids growing up
in jones county
yeah yeah or i'm going to call it free
state
[ __ ] [ __ ] all y'all i'm
starting my own [ __ ] i'll start my
own state with blackjack and hookers
but yeah so so yeah so we'll be back
tomorrow night about 5 p.m eastern time
i'm going to talk about some horror
movies and whatever else we start
rambling about when we
get drunk you know how we do
[Laughter]
all right so thanks everybody for
dropping by and we'll see you guys
tomorrow
bye